know even the chat GPT moment as I think
captured people's imagination Microsoft
CEO Satya Nadella may not welcome the
kind of attention his company's bet on
Advanced artificial intelligence is
getting last month Microsoft confirmed a
multi-billion dollar investment in open
AI the company behind chat GPT now the
company is restricting access to the AI
chat feature of its Bing browser after
reports of unsettling conversations with
the chatbot
Microsoft recently gave technology
reporters an opportunity to test the
chatbot before it was publicly released
one reporter wrote that after a long
conversation about the chatbot's
capabilities it said it was in love with
him and urged him to end his marriage it
also mused about skills it had but was
forbidden to use including developing a
biological weapon and stealing nuclear
secrets the chatbot took a belligerent
tone with another reporter comparing him
to Hitler and Stalin Microsoft is now
being talked about as a company that's
putting out an Innovative idea so for
them this is a win even if there are
some embarrassing bumps along the way
on Tuesday Microsoft announced Bing chat
will now answer only six questions per
conversation after which users are told
to start a new topic users will also be
limited to 60 Questions per day in total
Microsoft said long conversations quote
can confuse the underlying chat model
Google is also racing to bring AI
capabilities to its browser which it
says will be called Bard
observers say the model could power a
new technology and information
revolution but critics of artificial
intelligence have long speculated about
doomsday scenarios
the late physicist Stephen Hawking
warned fully intelligent AI could quote
spell the end of the human race Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles